sunscreen sticks can be really useful
but how are you meant to use them here's
why you probably shouldn't use a
sunscreen stick on its own I did an
experiment to find out how much I needed
to apply for the labeled SPF using some
really lightweight sticks I applied what
I thought was a generous layer of each
stick on average each one spent 55
seconds on my skin but I only got about
SPF 19. I did a second generous layer
which took another minute this got me up
to SPF 31. after a third minute I got an
average of SPF 42 but all of the sticks
were a slippery mess at this point and I
don't think I could get any more on my
skin the AED recommends four passes of a
sunscreen stick I'm not sure what they
based this off but I needed an average
of nine passes for SPF 19 and 34 passes
for SPF 42 so 6 could be good for
top-ups and tricky areas but they
probably aren't giving much protection
on their own